and I was cracking my head about you  know how to make a computer sentient I  was starting from wrong assumptions  Consciousness is not something you  create it's that within which every  creation happens in the stages of the  Hindus Valley three and a half thousand  years ago had come to the same answer so  what are your conclusions the inner  surface of your skull is beyond the  stars as you experience them under  materialism there is a real star beyond  your skull  but that's not the star you see it's the  thing that somehow modulates the star  you see so that's materialism and its  main problem is that nobody can provide  a satisfying account of how quantities  can possibly produce qualities